are you guys writing is a button Jackie
and so that must have everything
possible way we're doing it i was
thinking maybe so you know what you guys
see any other how did it work
where there times when you guys couldn't
lie and what sort of marriage already
bought the land like cats and dogs like
people do they didn't want to be around
fighting around a married couple of
words were getting ready to get divorced
no they literally people would leave the
left when the two of us will get
together it's the fact use that you have
collaborations closes John has
effectively john- them are the reason
for that is because there's a
complimentary or combination of each
other's weaknesses or overly driver win7
effectiveness of point we have an event
it's personal other iike a picture on
their losses like beyond you have every
picture if you thought i heard are
writing of 90,000 pictures writers the
CD if we charge you need baby that
picture together these interactions you
know and i can I don't mention i can
have some crazy idea i'm sort of crazy
out of your guy and I have some crazy
idea and translator ganja love with the
pictures you know I don't know anybody
else like that I I think you read the
bottom line here is that we are both
crazy about structure
I mean we just have in our blood to
understand the world who are
understanding and interpreting structure
that we share they immediately i had a
lot of people come from the album some
have this this is this i love the
structure and understanding the
structure and some don't
so I feel attractions people and I this
is the basis of a basic online for JA
yeah but I want to have one thing
because that there's another fundamental
way that were similar and that we're
problem solvers okay if I was going to
get stranded on a boat with no butter
somewhere office eat i wanted to be with
Tom because it's the only person i kill
we could solve the problem of our
situation appropriately together how
that's going to work between because we
were so complimentary amount and how are
you different have a god Rose number is
another test of how many full don't know
the point where ever I i love i love to
do the theoretical calculation even if
they're wrong in the blood
so I'm not ready to slice and I just I
just want to see how the mask those and
throwing old number and and run the
calculation and and I did we did we
needed everywhere trying to figure out
how many molecules or particles so I ran
the calculation and you know we don't do
that mean it's constant called
Avogadro's number and so I threw a
number and the calculation later on I
think you want to talk about I don't
know republished it the point was that i
had a number of ron white are magnitude
forwards magnet for you know how was the
critical care about you and I were
calculated how much treasure we would
need to get into another is a comedian
too hope to get a bit of that tracer
into people synaptic vesicle we're going
to be our first evidence that they
actually merged with the Seltzer huh so
we're calculating on the blackboard
what was the concentration of the full
pressure that we would need to add time
to figure out the volume of the
vegetable and that we got his number
grown by for orders of magnitude so we
calculated it would have to be 10 lower
hlp or something like that I got longer
i was going to happen so that worked out
that somebody figured you guys get the
part of an experiment work by the
sentence so like asking why father
collaborate right you're both smart you
could have done this
running around what was the Y deal with
each other after the sum of champions
are so many questions were asking you
know I get married and we're not
businessmen calculating a profit we feel
as you sing in our heart and we I felt
the attraction the judge where think he
had something that happens it happens
well that's what I also the issue as you
advance as you make little observations
even big love or get excited about your
work
it's just a whole lot more fun to share
it with out but it's totally with you
and got an understanding of it and it's
on the same captain struggling to get
with you are close to doing it all by
yourself
we were together some what like online
and we survey asked where I think I ask
you that very same question that is no
why are we doing this together why are
we here getting all this stuff and you
said to me he said the most important
thing in my life and I want to be with
washer discovering something going to
choose one full i wish somebody won't be
there much I want to be there with
happens and you know we were sure
committed the changes happen all
scientists want to share the results you
know where the broader communities that
want to make an impact make a
contribution and so on but this is a
moment in the plane
it's just your day-to-day operation
day-to-day thinking about science
somehow the whole lot more fun to share
with friends will camp just great
the first thing is that it's fun to work
with somebody at the second is that
there's the potential sartori that lies
beyond just having fun with each other
some insight that you won't have if
you're working along well as we've got a
whole other and everything but today i
might go to come out to Colorado a
disciple of differential expression and
work at work with something is really
getting a rash that lab that's that's
that don't touch the kind of thing we're
trying human brain science work together
sometimes
because trying to be so complex and
specialized that you can I you can get
things done but working together and you
have to give up the kind of wandering my
shop I want to glory everything after he
will know how I wish to share and the
ethics sharing and ethics and writing
papers together all that all it but
that's that that's a different issue
yeah that's the issue can be able to
kill him silence and yes that's a
critical ingredient but this is more
personal things shipped a whole lot more
fun to do it with a friend and
particularly when you been working
together for a long time and have
commons total common goal and just feel
that much sweeter